vous êtes enregistré avec elle et tout
vous connaissez tout du coup moi je dis
bah oui nanani ils disent bon on descend
en garde à vue on descend dans la garde
à vue de Charles de Gaulle
[Musique]
on est en entreprise à Bangui exactement
je suis venu en France j'avais 6 ans
j'ai grandi à Champigny-sur-Marne dans
le 94 au bois la B et après au boulot
regarde ce qui s'appelle les boulons mes
parents ils sont séparés quand on est
arrivé en France même pas un an après
dès que ma mère elle a couché de ma
petite sœur mes parents ils sont séparés
parce que mon père était violent avec ma
mère et il y a eu je crois que c'était
le coup de trop où la bagarre de trop et
donc ma mère elle s'est enfui ce soir là
avec avec ma petite sœur en fait elle
est partie enfin elle est partie elle
est revenue chercher ma petite sœur avec
la police ils ont pris mon petit frère
aussi parce qu'ils étaient petits et moi
du coup je suis resté deux trois jours
avec mon père et après bah ma mère est
revenue me chercher on est parti en
foyer par rapport aux violences qui a eu
dans mon enfance j'étais petite et c'est
vrai que ma mère à mon enfant ma mère ne
s'en a pas parlé beaucoup c'est plus en
grandissant qu'elle a commencé à mais je
te parle de très grande pour elle
c'était c'était trop bien en fait j'ai
la respecte encore plus pour ça mais
c'est vrai qu'en fait elle nous a
beaucoup préservé parce que je pense que
c'est aussi dans la culture africaine
les femmes africaines on est éduqué de
manière à pas montrer qu'on a donc je
pense que c'est aussi du fait de par son
éducation qu'elle nous a pas parlé de ça
en fait j'étais dans deux types de foyer
moi j'ai été dans le foyer pour quand tu
fais des bêtises parce que tu es trop
ouais tu es un perturbateur un enfant un
peu perturbé et quand on était jeune en
fait bah quand ma mère s'est séparée de
mon père on est parti dans des foyers
pour femme je crois que c'est pour les
femmes battues pour les femmes qui sont
seules ou pour les femmes en fait on
dormait tous les jours dans des foyers
différents et à un moment donné en fait
moi j'étais je me rappelle j'étais petit
j'étais en CP en fait je me souviens que
j'étais souvent fatigué je dormais sur
la table et tout à l'école parce que bah
c'est en général c'est pas dans le 9 4
c'est des trucs qui sont hyper loin et
c'est des trucs de secours donc
assistante sociale va t'appeler pour te
dire ah bah ce soir tu peux dormir là
pendant 2 jours et je vais trouver
quelque chose on a fait les foyers
pendant je crois un an et demi deux ans
je travaille hyper bien genre j'étais
vraiment dans le truc de en fait je
crois que je culpabiliser de ce que ma
mère elle a vécu genre le fait qu'elle
soit qu'elle était seule qu'elle est
galéré je pense que je culpabiliser ça
et du coup je me dis bah faut que je
travaille bien à l'école des fous que
conférence genre le ménage enfin il faut
que j'essaye de faire bon je faire à
manger non plus de ouf mais je faisais
des pâtes comme ça j'essaie de l'alléger
au maximum et en fait en grandissant je
pense qu'à un moment donné je lui en ai
voulu de ça genre enfin j'en ai pas
voulu parce que c'est pas elle qui m'a
mis ses responsabilité là mais
indirectement quand tu grandis dans une
famille monopara tonne par directement
plus de responsabilités qu'un enfant qui
grandit dans une famille parentale saine
on va dire aujourd'hui oui j'ai besoin
de lui montrer que bah en fait tout ce
qu'elle a fait je la remercie je la
remercierai jamais assez parce que
jusqu'à pas très longtemps je l'ai enfin
je la je l'ai beaucoup fait souffrir ma
mère dans ma classe d'adolescence dans
mes bêtises dans mes erreurs elle a
beaucoup subi en fait en fait je me suis
excusé bah je pense que toutes les fois
où j'ai fait des bêtises je me suis
excusé là la dernière
erreur en date je me suis excusé je
pense que je m'en veux encore donc c'est
peut-être pour ça toutes les mamans sont
des exemples particulièrement les mères
qui se battent seuls ou qui sont
peut-être en coup il y a des femmes qui
sont en couple mais qui se battent seuls
pour leurs enfants genre je parle pas
forcément que des femmes battues je
parle de ma mère mais je parle de toutes
les mamans en général alors en fait
j'avais pour vous dire la vérité c'est
moi je suis quelqu'un qui c'est pas que
je suis en concurrence avec mon frère
mais genre avant j'étais très garçon
manqué mais je pense que c'était pour
prouver parce que mon frère a la
différence genre il a fait le beau but
j'étais tout genre la réussite et tout
donc je voulais toujours prouver que et
ben en fait en vrai j'ai commencé donc à
avoir en fait à traîner avec des mecs de
cité et j'étais aussi dans encore dans
ce truc là de de fit banlieue pourtant
je travaillais à côté mais j'étais dans
ce truc là de fit banlieue de vouloir
prouver que genre j'ai pas peur je suis
une racaille un truc débile au début bon
bah j'ai fréquenté certains mecs qui
faisaient de l'argent sale
particulièrement battus et à ce moment
là j'étais donc avec une petite que je
connais donc une petite de chez moi elle
aussi elle a déjà été un peu dans les
stupides et tout de même pour partir à
force de France avec des stups dans leur
balises le jour du départ qui s'est
passé c'est que tout simplement bah
quand elle elle s'est fait attrapée tu
sais quand tu fais des passages comme ça
vous devez pas rester ensemble
c'est-à-dire que chacune elle
s'enregistre de son côté vous faites
comme si vous ne connaissez pas jusqu'à
que vous arrivez à la et en l'occurrence
je sais pas pourquoi genre à ce moment
là moi je lui dis alors que je sais que
moi je suis pas chargé je dis c'est quoi
vas-y viens on s'en fout on reste
ensemble il nous appelle donc au truc de
pour l'embarquement il nous appelle il
nous appelle et moi je lui dis ah ben je
vais aller aux toilettes j'arrive et
donc elle est pas pour embarquer moi je
vais aux toilettes et qu'on sort des
toilettes en fait on rentre dans la
passerelle je vois qu'en fait elle est
avec des mecs qui ont des brassard
orange en fait donc je me suis dit bon
soit je passe et je fais comme si je la
connais pas toi en fait je peux pas en
fait tu vois mais en vrai je peux pas et
c'est là que je vois que je suis pas une
racaille c'est qu'en vrai je peux enfin
je pouvais pas alors que la règle aurait
été que écoute elle elle a elle a pris
ses risques aussi elle savait c'était
quoi les risques toi maintenant c'est
chacun sa chance et donc je passe à côté
ils me disent oui vous vous êtes
enregistré avec elle et tout vous
connaissez et tout j'ai du coup moi je
dis bah oui nanani ils me disent bon bah
on descend en garde à vue on descend
dans la garde à vue Charles de Gaulle et
au final il se disait bah c'est elle
c'est moi la tête vu que moi j'avais
enfin moi j'avais rien j'avais ils ont
rien trouvé dans ma valise j'avais
vraiment rien tu sais avant le jugement
pour l'avocat il vient de voir que c'est
un moment de dépôt pour te dire bon
écoute et moi en fait la brise disait
mais des fois le genre reviens sur ce
que tu sur tes dire parce que en soi tu
n'as rien et en fait la bokai il me
disait clairement tu vas prendre la même
peine qu'elle parce que c'est de la
complicité mais j'étais encore tu sais
mais en fait pour te dire la vérité je
crois que je me disais encore je vais
pas aller en prison vraiment je suis
tombé en prison pour complicité de
stupide je suis resté deux ans et demi
le retour à la réalité il est dur parce
qu'en fait tu sais dans les mafs en tout
cas à Fresnes dans les mars c'est
compliqué parce qu'en fait quand tu as
passé une peine de plus de 2 ans tu es
considéré comme une grosse peine et moi
j'ai pris quatre ans donc j'ai été
considéré comme une grosse peine et du
coup je devais faire un dossier
d'orientation pour aller dans une
centrale où les femmes qui ont pris des
grosses peines sont bons mais moi je
suis une stupéficiant donc je juge pas
les gens sur les délits qu'ils ont fait
mais en général dans les centrales c'est
plus des criminels moi je fais mon
dossier d'orientation je suis transféré
d'ailleurs à Rio la veille dans deux
jours avant crédence de façon m'évasion
là et en fait va le le retour à la
réalité je pense que si j'étais resté à
Fresnes il aurait été plus simple que
quand j'étais transféré en fait en
centrale parce que je suis resté 8 mois
en centrale et en centrale en fait c'est
ta vie enfin un moment donné tu vis
dedans parce que les amis dans ta
chambre un petit fauteuil un petit pendu
tu vois c'est chez toi genre la cellule
c'est carrément ta maison limite après
tu es plus dans le truc de je vais pas
sortir c'est une sauce pour moi la
prison c'est une société on cuisine une
communement on a les clés de notre
cellule donc en fait ta cellule appart
tu vois limite tu dis ah bah en fait je
suis bien ici genre et en fait ton
cerveau s'habitue à ça et ton cerveau
s'habitue tellement à ça que tu as plus
forcément envie de sortir pour affronter
ce qu'on sait qu'il y a dehors les
jugements les préjugés juste affrontés
genre le regard des gens en soi pas
forcément que pour moi mais pour ma mère
pour mon frère pour mes sœurs genre les
pauvres un truc j'ai le plus même des
trucs de ma propre vie à moi en vrai
parce que quand tu es une femme ton
entre 25 et 30 ans c'est l'âge où tu te
je t'émancipes on va dire où tu trouves
la voix ou tu veux aller moi en
l'occurrence bah à ce moment là j'étais
un peu autre part comment je me suis
retrouvé dans alors quand je suis sorti
le temps de marée insertion je me suis
mis en couple j'étais en fait quand
tu sens le pneu et une autre personne
genre la société t'as mais c'est un
système qui te bronze mais vraiment qui
te qui te brûle tellement au point que
tu sais plus quitter en tant que femme
tu sais plus qui t'es en tant que sœur
je sais plus qui était en tant que
personne tout court tu vois moi je sais
que pendant longtemps genre quand je
marchais j'étais enfin je me dis les
gens ils savent que je suis parti en
prison tu vois tu as des parents comme
ça genre bah des trucs tout bête je sais
que j'ai encore un toc c'est que je
regarde tout le temps quand on parle je
regarde là là là là parce que c'est trop
de il y a beaucoup d'informations alors
que quand on présente c'est peut-être
pas ton sens visuel il est comme ça en
fait tu vois donc t'as pas ça et tu as
pas ça tu vois j'étais encore dans ce
truc là en fait je et c'est peut-être
pour ça que les gens ils comprennent pas
maintenant peut-être que les gens ils
vont comprendre quand j'ai fait la télé
qui disait mais elle a pas confiance en
elle et tout bah je pense que ça aussi
ça j'avais déjà pas confiance en moi
mais je pense que ça ça le coup de
Martin qui a qui voilà et quand tu sors
en fait tu sais pas qui tu es tu dois
vraiment tu es en recherche de toi-même
tu es en recherche de qu'est-ce que je
vais faire qu'est-ce que je sais faire
qu'est-ce que je peux faire tu vois à ce
moment-là bah je me suis mis en couple
avec une personne cette personne là elle
était pas vraiment elle t'a un peu
négative pour moi ça veut dire que
j'étais encore plus dans un truc de je
suis une mauvaise personne
j'ai Paris ici et je suis rentré un peu
dans un cercle vicieux comme ça et quand
je suis parti à Dubaï en fait bah j'ai
rencontré jazz et là en l'occurrence
c'est comme si la ville en moi comme
dans un livre ouvert genre parce que je
l'avais déjà vu deux trois fois et je me
rappelle Laurine était un pitbull toi
parce que j'étais agressive en fait tu
vois je savais pas comment me faire
accepter par les gens et du coup c'est
même pas que je savais pas comment faire
accepter par les gens je me dis ils vont
pas m'accepter mais pas forcément que la
société tout court et j'étais très
agressive et en fait elle a réussi à
voir tout le travail que j'ai fait cette
carapace que j'ai créé durant toute ma
vie parce qu'en soit c'est pas que la
prison c'est aussi la banlieue qui je
pense que les jeunes de banlieue mais
beaucoup comme ça on se crée cette
carapace dont des fois en deux secondes
genre elle m'a dit ouais tu es quelqu'un
de très sensibles tu as fait ça mais il
faut pas que tu t'en veuilles et est-ce
que les gens ils savent pas c'est que
c'est vrai que mon frère pendant moi
pendant toute ma peine mon frère s'est
occupé de moi financièrement mais mon
frère n'est pas venu me rappeler parce
qu'il était fâché genre il était déçu de
moi genre
et il m'a dit en gros bah je viendrai
pas de voir mais je m'occuperai de tout
ce qui ferait financier après financier
genre tout enfin tout ce qui était mes
habits les baskets l'avocat il s'occuper
de tous sauf de venir me voir sur le
coup ça m'a fait beaucoup de peine après
j'ai compris parce que mon frère il est
il est en fait on est pareil mais on
réagit moi je suis une femme donc c'est
quelqu'un qui va il a il a cette
carapace là de je suis tout le temps
rapide je suis tout seul et je pense que
on est tellement fusionnel que pour le
coup je pense que ça l'aurait détruit de
voir comme ça genre de l'autre côté en
fait c'est lui et jazz qui me disent lui
au début il a un peu peur il a il a un
peu de retenue il se dit bon elle va
finir à faire des histoires encore et
puis il a un peu peur et après il me
fait revenir donc je vais à Dubaï un
petit pan et je reviens et au final je
reste
et je reviens et bah j'ai aussi jazz qui
me s'apprend et qui est dans ce truc de
elle a ce truc de vouloir me sauver en
fait je crois que c'est ça elle est dans
ce truc de
je peux pas la laisser genre rester dans
ce tourbillon tourbillon là et
indirectement ma mère et ma sœur elles
auraient pu faire mais j'allais pas
rester dans l'environnement
l'environnement dans lequel j'ai testé
la banlieue et même Paris valait mieux
que je coupe dans cette environnement là
que je puisse évoluer dans ma
réinsertion d'une bonne manière que de
rester à Paris et de risquer de
fréquenter des gens un peu durs
récemment je sais pas si sûr que je
parle à mon poste concernant l'histoire
sera chirurgie esthétique moi j'ai fait
un BBL en Tunisie en collaboration un
BBL c'est donc on prend de la graisse de
ton corps et on la met dans une autre
partie en fait c'est de la liposculture
en fait on peut redessine tout est
encore dans les fesses à ce moment là
déjà j'étais beaucoup plus grosse je
venais de rentrer dans la téléréalité et
je enfin je recevais des collaborations
en veux-tu en voilà et là on me propose
genre bah écoute tu veux te refaire tout
ce que tu aimes pas tiens vas-y viens
c'est gratuit donc j'ai pas réfléchi
genre la question c'est pas pourquoi je
l'ai fait c'est juste que j'ai pas
réfléchi moi en soi je j'avais grossi
mais j'étais pas non plus une papa tu
faisais un 38 faut pas mentir je dis la
vérité genre j'étais complexée un peu
mais j'aurais fait un régime pendant
deux mois ma belle à ce moment là je
sortais de la saison 4 de l'agity Family
je venais de rentrer dans les réseaux
sociaux ça faisait peut-être 4-5 mois
sur Twitter on m'a pris Petit Potam
genre les gens enfin j'en ai vu des
trucs bon dieu merci moi je suis
quelqu'un de l'humour parce que pour le
coup il avait vraiment de l'humour mais
il terminait si on veut là les trucs je
pense que les gens pensaient peut-être
que j'avais confiance en moi mais en
vrai j'avais pas du tout confiance en
moi donc indirectement j'étais je
prenais toutes les informations et je
l'ai gardé et ça me nourrissait mais pas
de la bonne manière en fait je pense que
ça ça a beaucoup joué c'était pas des
complexes que moi j'avais c'était
complexes que les gens m'ont créé en
fait ma chirurgien c'était mal passé
parce que bon déjà à la base je crois
que j'avais demandé une lipo du ventre
après on dit oui si tu veux on fait un
bébé je dis ok bébé quand ils ont fait
le bébé elle j'avais en fait le la
canule donc qui sert à aspirer la
graisse le chirurgien la montée trop au
niveau de mes seins donc ça m'a pété ma
glande ma mère du coup j'ai eu une
hémorragie et quand je me suis levée en
fait de mon anesthésie donc le premier
jour je vois qu'on change un sac qui est
beaucoup plus gros que l'autre mais
il le lendemain genre ça comme ça il est
hyper dur et tout donc moi j'appelle en
plus je suis parti seul j'appelle jazz
en pleurs je me dis ouais voilà il s'est
passé ça ça donc elle me dit non mais il
y a un problème donc elle elle les
appelle comment ça faire scandale et
tout et le chirurgien lui il était en
weekend donc en gros bah je vais faire
un truc chirurgien ils reviennent donc
je suis resté pendant 48 heures comme ça
avec mon sac il grossissait qui
grossissait et quand il est venu genre
il m'a sorti la fin de oui en fait tu as
eu une hémorragie enfin je peux pas
avoir d'hémorragie si enfin j'ai pas eu
de l'épotion à ce niveau-là au niveau du
ventre logiquement c'est sûr que c'était
la canule et entre-temps bah jazz elle a
appelé déjà à Paris il me dit bon c'est
tout simple en fait c'est juste que la
canule il a dû monter trop haut pas du
tout c'est 50 de ma mère elle est en
train de faire une hémorragie maintenant
je parle de le dire j'avais cette gêne
parce que je mentais un peu à ma
communauté en vrai tu vois parce que en
vrai ça allait très très mal quand
j'étais là-bas mais je faisais quand
même des petits snap en mode ouais ça va
mamie et vu que j'étais dans ce truc là
en fait de faire un peu la mytho bah je
suis rentré en fait je me suis dit vas-y
oublie tout ça et enfin sauf que j'ai eu
un autre problème quand je suis rentré
ils ont dû mettre des implants ma merde
du coup et quand je suis rentrée j'ai eu
une infection dans la fesse droite
maintenant en l'occurrence c'est vrai
que la chirurgie c'est devenu mode est
encore pire avec nous les gens de
téléréalité parce que avec les
collaborations on en a fait clairement
un business vous en avez été c'est on en
a fait un business et il est chirurgiens
et les cliniques on en fait un business
grâce à nous aussi j'ai peur de mourir
je me suis dit c'est un truc des fois
anesthésie générale en quatre jours je
fais des anesthésie j'ai peur de mourir
genre et en soi pourquoi j'ai plus
confiance en moi mais c'est ni grâce à
la chirurgie ni grâce aux réseaux
sociaux j'ai plus confiance en moi mais
grâce je pense à mon entourage et au
dépassement de moi parce que je me suis
rendu compte et peut-être aussi grâce à
mon entourage que je pouvais être
capable de faire des choses aujourd'hui
les guys je suis créatrice de contenu
zappez-moi comme de télé-réalité de
façon je n'ai jamais enfin j'ai j'ai
aimé faire de la réalité dans le cadre
de la JLC j'ai aimé faire de la
téléréalité dans le cadre de la Villa
des cœur BR isés mais passer la bataille
des clans j'ai détesté faire de la
télé-réalité et j'ai détesté tout ce
qu'il y a autour de la téléréalité les
gars j'ai ouvert ma chaîne youtube et
d'ailleurs je suis sur un podcast avec
mélanight et Marwa qui s'appelle
l'équipe menteuse on parle de sexe sans
tabou et sur ma chaîne youtube bientôt
vous aurez toutes les Storytime de toute
ma vie enfin